[Music]
don't forget to enter our amazon gift
card giveaway all you have to do is like
the video and comment
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about the robert's rebellion
sequence that's confirmed to take place
in the final season in a form of
flashback
it's been confirmed by none other than
george rr martin flashbacks have played
quite a big role in game of thrones thus
far
in the season 7 finale bran upon being
told that jon is not a bastard
but rather a legitimate son of liana and
rhaegar targaryen
he uses his green sight and witness as a
secret wedding for himself
this flashback is without a doubt the
most important flashback we've seen thus
far
as brain explained to sam it revealed
that robert's rebellion was in fact
built on a lie
rehgar did not kidnap and rape lyanna
she loved him and he loved her
their secret marriage also means that
jon snow is rehgar's lawful son
and the rightful heir to the armed
throne ahead of reiger's younger sister
dany
season 8 filming news are confirming
that we'll see more of regard targaryen
in the final season
which means we'll get one or two major
regular targaryen flashbacks
will scolding or rhaegar targaryen
posted a selfie at europa hotel in
belfast
and soon after deleted it now what does
this mean
in short if game of thrones sector in
this case an actor that portrays rhaegar
is thing in malphus
it means that he will appear in the
upcoming season as he is shooting some
scenes in belfast
also the fact that other game of thrones
sectors starting the same hotel such as
an actor that portrays euron greyjoy
is suggesting that the regular targaryen
flashback is most certainly coming in
the final season
we'll firstly get a regular flashback in
attorney at harold hall
which will explain to us how jon's
parents fell in love and why they
decided to run away
what was that important for liana and
rehgar to leave without an explanation
to put the seven kingdoms into the state
of chaos to start a rebellion
i'm expecting her showrunners to show us
currently unknown reason
which led the nair to the armed throne
prince rhaegar to run away with lyanna
and that they almost destroyed house
targaryen i'm wondering what was that
important for them to run away without
explanation
the event which resulted vilina's father
and brother getting killed and triggered
himself along with his father
wife and two children also getting
killed the season 7 finale finally
confirmed what i believed
the most loud prince rhaegar did not
kidnap lyanna he loved her and she loved
him
regardless fell in love in love that
resulted with death for both of them
along with majority of their families
now let me explain to you how that love
happened
which is also very simple and probably a
few of you who thought about us have
already come to this conclusion
by this theory we'll see a few
flashbacks of attorney at harehole
where it all started the great tourney
at harrenhal was the largest tournament
held in the history of westeros
hosted by lord walter vent in the year
of the fall spring the tourney proved
faithful for the future of the seven
kingdoms
as crown prince rhaegar targaryen crown
lina stark the queen of love and beauty
at the end
forsaking his wife elia martell and
leading to robert's rebellion
but let's get a bit back let's take a
look on no major events that took place
in this great tourney
as i was saying during the year of the
fall springs in the height of summer
walter bend hosted the largest turn in
the history of westeros
attracting knights and lords from across
the seven kingdoms with its spectacle
and large champions purse
some believe that the entire tourney had
in fact been organized by crown prince
rhaegar targaryen
to gather the great lords of westeros
and address the madness of his father
king gary is the second targaryen
perhaps even to remove him from the iron
throne
anyways the first notable event occurred
on the onset of the tourney
enjoying the warm spring day young
holland reed was set upon by three
squires two knights from house frey
high and blunt they snatched away his
spear and knocked him to the ground
cursing him for a frog eater every time
he tried to rise they shot him down
and kicked him and he curled up on the
ground but then they heard a shout
that's my father's man you're kicking
how old the she-wolf lyanna stark the
young daughter of lord rickard stark
warden of the north and holland's liege
lord
lyanna laid into the squires to the turn
sword scattering them all
holland was bruised and bloodied so she
took him back to her tent to clean his
cuts
there he met her brothers while brandon
who led them
quite better than benjen who was the
youngest of the four later holland eight
and drank with his fellow northmen under
haron's great roof
that evening prince rhaegar sang a song
so said that it brought tears to lena's
eyes
but when benjamin teased her about it
she poured wine over his head
however the hole soon went quiet as king
air centered with his kingsguard
having not left the red cape in years he
shocked everyone with his long yellow
fingernails
tangled beard and unwashed hair he would
go from hysterical laughter to weeping
to rage within moments
making his madness plain for everyone to
see however a cheer burst from the crowd
as he called for sir jamie lannister
to kneel before him and swear north of
the kingsguard as sir jaime was admired
for his courage gallantry and
swordsmanship
during the proceedings holland spotted
the three squires who had attacked him
standing with their knights
lyanna and her siblings suffered to help
him to prepare for a jousting match
against knights
i could find your horse and some armor
that might fit benching over to holland
lord reed thanked him but gave no answer
much as he wished to have his vengeance
he feared he would only make a fool of
himself and shame his people
the next day in the tourney the three
night school squires had beaten holland
unseated their opponents and earned a
place among the champions
but late in the afternoon as the shadows
grew long a mystery knight appeared on
the list
known as the knight of the laughing tree
here she was short and clad in
ill-fitting armor cobble together from
different suits
and hailed a shield painted with a
laughing heart tree the card white
weirwood of the old gods
the three knights this mystery knight
challenged were the ones who squires
bullet holland
all three knights fell against this
mystery knight when the fallen foes saw
to ransom their horses
and armor the knight of the laughing
tree's voice boomed through his or her
skeleman told them
teacher squires honor that shall be
ransom enough
once the fatty knights chastise their
squires sharply they allowed to keep
their horses and armor
while the crowd was cheering for this
mystery night the mad king however was
furious
in his madness he suspected the traitor
in his midst
declaring knight of the laughing trees
enemy aries ordered robert baratheon to
unmask him
the following morning however when the
heralds blew their trumpets
and the king took his seat the knight of
the laughing tree had vanished
the king became anger by this cern that
someone close to him had given warning
this traitor who will not show his face
angry aries sent his men including
prince rhaegar to search for the
vanished knight
but only his shield could be found
abandoned on a tree
the same night by this theory knight of
the laughing tree is lena stark
and that's how love between her and
noble reagar happened
the story of the knight of the laughing
tree is given by miro and the novels
exactly as it's given in this video
and although it's never been entirely
confirmed who the mystery knight was
the implication of the books does seem
to heavily hint it was leona stark
lyanna as her later name zarya stark
wanted to learn to use a sword then was
a great writer
liana's skillet horse riding is remarked
on several times by characters who had
known her
in a nod to this the first time that
lyanna appears on screen beginning in
season 6
she's shown coming back to winterfell
from a day's riding on her horse
remember what sir jamie lannister once
said the jousters are only as skilled at
jousting as they are in horseback riding
they're even more close the knight of
the laughing tree was short
had a booming voice which was not a
man's voice was having a mismatched
armor which means that the knight did
not have access to regular armor
with telltale marking on it bore the
beer with the image on the shield
which implies a connection to the old
gods and the north and as a final
confirmation this night challenge that
fought only against those knights was
squire's bullet holland reed
until liana came to his aid you might be
confused now and are probably wondering
while lyanna being the knight of the
laughing tree has to do with rhaegar
how liana stark and rhaegar met and how
did they fall in love
well rhaegar figured out who mysterious
knight was but let's get a bit back
as already said the turn at harrenhal
was the first time after a good amount
of years that the mad king had left the
red keep
since he was extremely paranoid he
thought that the mystery knight of the
laughing tree was an enemy
and this same knight wanted to kill him
which led him to send out his son
rhaegar
in order to find the same knight in a
short amount of time rhaegar brought the
mysterious knight shield to his father
very report that it's only found by this
theory reiger lied
he found the mystery knight of the
laughing tree and discovered that it was
this young fearless beautiful ianna
stark that had stood up for her father's
bannerman
rhaegar could not bring her to his
father since he knew how it would end
with her being burned alive noble and
kind prince could not do anything but to
take her shield and report to his father
that it's only found
let's also remember a fact that only a
few days after this rhaegar won the
joust
rode past his wife alia and crowned
leona stark his queen of love and beauty
as he laid a chrono bloom into rose's in
her lap
shortly after the turning lyanna ran
away with rhaegar and married him in a
secret ceremony in dorne
together they had a son who would become
known as jon snow
there are a few more clues that are
making the great tourney at harrenhal
flashback even more likely to come true
george r martin company stated that even
though they are currently working on
game of thrones prequels the robert's
rebellion is most definitely not one of
them
george explained that by the time the
song of ice in fire and by the time the
game of thrones show is over we'll know
every important thing
and we'll learn no secrets about what
happened in that time period
he then finishes by saying it would feel
too much like a twice tall tale
this pretty much confirms that we'll get
a few flashbacks that will finally show
us how rhaegar and lyanna fell in love
invited they decided to run away without
leaving a note to their families
but it also confirms they will most
likely get a flashback of a legendary
fight between robert and rhaegar
about which i'm going to talk more now
let's take a look on this shot published
in official game of thrones youtube
channel
it's been out for a year or so and it's
basically in production tease
if you look closely on this shot you'll
notice a yellow shield with black bats
all over it
that heraldry that consists of nine
black bats over a gold field is of house
vent
the same house that hosted the great
tourney at hair hall taking into account
that this shield has not yet appeared
then knowing that the house fent is
extinct as well as knowing that there's
only one season left
it's got to appear in the final season
with that being said let's focus on a
fight between rhaegar and robert
that we are most likely going to see in
season 8 in a flashback
george armor announced that we'd see
every important event that happened
during robert's rebellion
and since the battle the trident was the
most important event i think it's safe
to say that you'll finally get to see
this legendary fight on screen
as we'll probably know at this point the
battle the trident was the battle that
ultimately determined the outcome of
robert's rebellion
the battle was decided when robert and
rhaegar met in single combat on
horseback in stream
robert eventually crushed rhaegar's
chest with a blow of his warhammer
this battle was the most important event
during the rebellion as they decided the
winner of the war
so the battle by itself already has to
be shown in order for us to feel like
watching advice told story
if robert sebelia never gets its own
show however even though this by itself
would definitely have to be put on
screen
what if there are some secrets we don't
know regarding this battle
what if robber did not win against
rhaegar what if prince rhaegar defeated
him and told him to yield
since he did not want to kill robert
rhaegar told him that lyanna loves him
and he loves her
robert dealed it rhaegar helped robert
get up and when rhaegar was ready
when he put down his sword at that
moment robert smashed his warhammer into
prince rhaegar's chest
that's why robert was never happy he
knew lyanna loved reikar
and rhaegar did not hurt lyanna robert
neuraeger was a better fighter
he defeated regard only because rhaegar
was too noble and kind to finish him
so robert used the situation yielded and
killed him and he was not expecting it
that's why he drank himself to an early
grave trying to forget it all
i mean it's all there it's been in front
of us for years
during his battle against rhaegar robert
was wounded and after that battle he was
never
truly happy some say it's because of
lyanna
but the truth is robert never loved
lyanna that much
as a matter of fact he slept with many
girls after his marriage was arranged
lyanna
in this theory the truth why robert was
never happy again after the battle of
the trident
is not only because his wife ran away
with rhaegar out of love and not against
her will
but also because the same man lyanna
fell in love defeated him in combat and
spared his life
only for robert to kill him out of anger
even though he healed it then rehgar was
not expecting it
so basically in this theory robert
knowley and i loved rhaegar and he loved
her
robert also knew rhaegar was a better
fighter and he knows he would have been
dead if not for aker's mercy
and that's why he's been drinking
himself to an early grave ever since
he could not accept it that's why robert
kills rhaegar in his dreams every night
over and over again
regardless if this crazy theory of mind
comes true we'll most certainly get to
see the most important battle of
westeros since season 8 in a form of
flashback
in conclusion with regard being back for
season 8 i think it's safe to say that
we can expect a flashback or two of the
great tornad hair hole
that was the beginning of a doomed love
between kain and noble rhaegar and
beautiful and brave lyanna
as well as a flashback of a fight
between rehgar and robert regardless if
there are some secrets
and as always i hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our channel and i hope
to see you in the next one
peace